>> WELCOME BACK TO LEXUS
INTERMISSION REPORT AND
LOOK WHO IS BACK.
CHARLES BARCLAY HAS THE
BLOCKER ON THE CORRECT
HAND, THE CORRECT WAY,
HOLDING THE GOALIE STICK
SOMEWHAT PROPERLY.
IT IS, BY THE WAY.
YES.
HE HAD A NOTE FOR YEAR,
BY THE WAY, PEKKA RINNE.
HE RETIRED.
THIS IS HIS STUFF.
HE CAN USE IT.
HE WANTED TO KNOW WHY
YOU WOULD CHOOSE TO PLAY
AGAINST JORDAN IN
BASKETBALL AND NOW
AGAINST WAYNE GRETZKY
AND HOCKEY.
IT SEEMS LIKE A BAD
IDEA.
>> I WILL START AT THE
TOP AND WORK MY WAY
DOWN.
>> THIS IS GREAT.
SHOOTOUT TO END ALL
SHOOTOUTS.
YOU ARE IN GO AND YOU GO
AGAINST WAYNE GRETZKY
AND HE WILL TAKE FIVE
SHOTS HERE.
>> FIVE SHOTS?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYONE
EXPECT YOU TO MAKE IT
THROUGH ALL FIVE.
>> I WILL MAKE IT TO ALL
FIVE.
HOW MANY AM I GOING TO
STOP IS THE QUESTION.
>> TWO.
>> RICK HAS TWO.
>> I HAVE FAITH IN YEAR,
CHUCK.
I SAY THREE. I GOT YOU.
THREE.
>> I DON'T THINK HE WILL
SAVE ONE OF THEM.
I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU ARE GOING AGAINST
THE GREAT ONE, BUDDY.
>> GRETZKY, HERE WE GO.
GRETZKY AND BARCLAY, THE
SHOOTOUT.
>> LET'S GO.
>> HERE WE GO.
SHOT ONE.
>> TOP CHEESE.
>> 1-1.
GOT A PIECE.
>> TWO.
I NEED TWO.
>> GET HIM SOME PADS.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
>> THAT IS NOT IN.
THAT IS NOT IN.
>> HANG ON A SECOND HAD
HANG ON A SECOND.
NO GO.
>> 2-3.
>> YOU GOT TO STOP ONE
OF THESE.
>> FIVE-HOLE.
>> MY GOALTENDING COACH
SUCKS.
>> BUTTERFLY.
GO DOWN LIKE THIS.
>> STRAIN OR SOMETHING.
>> IT'S WORTH IT.
>> STATE OF THE MINORS,
BUDDY.
-- STAY TO THE MINORS,
>> YOU CAN BE BACK IN
TWO WEEKS AND THE PHONE
NEVER RINGS.
>> THE BEST PART OF THE
STORY IS YOU JUST HAVE
TO SAY YOU STOPPED SHOT
FROM WAYNE GRETZKY.
>> THAT IS HOW IT WILL
GO DOWN TONIGHT.
THANK YOU, BROTHER.
WELCOME TO THE TURNER
FAMILY.
>> IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
LIKE THIS.
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE A
SHOT AGAINST GRETZKY?
COME ON.
PLAQUES HE IS THE
CHARLES BARCLAY OF
HOCKEY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> THAT'S NO FAIR.
GRETZKY IS WEARING A
CHEST PROTECTOR.
>> OH!
>> NO.
>> DID YOU EVER WEAR A
SWEATER ON THE SHOW?
>> SWEATING ON JUST --
IN JUST HIS SHIRT.
>> 1972?
>> TWO THINGS HAPPENS
TONIGHT.
THIS IS THE LAST TIME
YO